morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy Thursday no
Wednesday with hump day April 15th it
should have been tax day but here's a
bright spot in the darkness that is
quarantine your taxes aren't due today
they're actually due in July and instead
you're getting money from the government
hey stimulus check Hey oh that's funny
like I'm I'm tick-tock it's like famous
relative check stimulus check that it's
like golden I'm such like in a tick tock
mentality cuz I'm like kind of a star oh
I'm not in the tick tock mentality right
now I haven't talked in like a week I
think I'm just like week on week off by
the way I go through the same kind of
rigid clothes you know so I look forward
to getting back on the talk see what the
kids are up to but I was just getting a
little tapped out on the talk it's such
a beautiful day in New York though done
it's not too warm though so it's not
really like sitting Sarah alfresco
weather because you'd have to wear like
a Down coat it's deceiving unless you're
in New York you know that it's actually
like 40 degrees it's freezing but it
looks beautiful the sun is shining and
in the quarantine times that's all we
can ask for because I'm not even feeling
sad that I'm not outside cuz I genuinely
don't want to be outside like when I
walked Theo this morning was absolutely
freezing but in the quarantine times I
actually love a rainy day you know
because it's like oh we're not missing
much I would be inside anyway
you're like watching Twilight exactly
when everything of watching iconic high
school series I'm sorry like I watched
the toast movie of the day last night in
High School Musical 3 and it was
everything like from the depths of my
soul it was so fulfilling that's such a
good feeling to go back and watch
something that really impacted you as a
young child and to know that it still
has that same impact that same resonance
I look forward to recapping it with you
guys what a fantastic choice I'm so glad
for my for my heart and my soul that I
watched the High School Musical trilogy
in the past three days and I highly
recommend you do the same can I ask you
a question because on the show yesterday
we both made a vow and given what my
hair looks like I'm like your hair looks
like it looks like my hair is oh
naturally and yours is not I did not use
any heat I did not use any heat I used
pomade
okay I just lick it back I used it looks
like a straight oh well now like my hair
is weirdly straight
does it really shower hair it's so curl
obviously that's what my hair looks like
now I have the shower which is crazy
though because my hair used to be so
curly those used to be way more
straight no-mind used to be like so wavy
now it's like I'm getting old my hair is
changing and it's like so not cute
anymore my hair is just kind of limp
naturally but if I needed to like look
straight I can make it look straight ya
know I mean then you know a little flat
iron over your pea psyche never mind
nothing he mean either no I didn't do
anything like but today was such a
relaxing morning no it was and I feel
like my hair like I feel like it's like
an aquamarine when her ears are like
whispering compliments I feel like my
hair is like thank you aquamarine is
also such a good movie cuz you get movie
bit of town on Disney Plus and I have
not on any streaming services so justice
for sara paxton she's constantly being
shafted she's constantly being shafted
she wasn't appreciated as the young
talent that she was and now it's like
over for her I completely completely
agree the tragic story he was on that
show about models with Mischa Barton and
it should have like totally hit but was
she yeah I forget what it was called but
it was like about a model apartment in
New York and Mischa Barton was like the
aging you know has been model and is it
a reality show
no oh whoa scripted show and Tara Paxton
was like the young up-and-comer and
doesn't it sound like a recipe for
success and iconic but no of course
since I liked it it got canceled yeah
well you're a curse to all good
television shows I completely completely
agree I went back to input three for the
first time in like weeks to watch mine
of home girls this morning and I saw my
DVR and it just like gave me anxiety I
have eleven episodes of dynasty to catch
up on three Blue Bloods two shots of
sunset the only thing I really keep up
with is housewives pomp rules and
Kardashians other things just like they
gather dust in my DVR and I'm even
though I love dynasty I'm just like not
in a place in my life where I can catch
up on it I have to say something like so
upsetting because you know I ride so
hard for dizzy this season has been so
bad and I watch weeks week and I'm like
you know suppressing my emotions but two
weeks to goes how can I sat down to
watch and I actually turned it off in
the middle I was like I can't watch this
maybe if I had a stack of episodes I
wouldn't be I did so much but it's been
really bad well that happened to me
actually last night I've been having
this Renaissance with One Tree Hill and
me and been just like stumbled on alike
a group of episodes that were just
unbearable like everything's going wrong
and it's annoying like the people that I
like like Sofia Bush can't catch a break
she's like stuck in such a bad spot like
she's pregnant and like everyone knows
about it and she's like my hero and
she's just not having a good
and then like Payton who's like the most
annoying character on the show her
ever-changing hair drives me insane like
she's thriving now and like she likes
Lucas and like I'm just I can't watch
shows where the people I like like
aren't doing are thriving
I completely agree and the people I
don't like are thriving and I don't know
if like when everyone was watching it in
the fourth season did everybody like
Sophia Bush over Peyton or am I wrong
like I don't know because I'm not
watching it with the group yes that is
sometimes difficult to navigate yeah but
it just got to a point where like me and
Ben I've been watching like six episodes
a night like after two or three we just
turned it off and went to sleep
damn all so um speaking of watching we
did get a a promo code for Love sack
which me I said that we were gonna do
because we've been talking about our
loves texts so much this is not
sponsored not apparently love our love
stacks we keep talking about them so we
wanted to get you a code for 25% off so
use code comfy 25 comf why two five if
you want 25% off your love stack it's
been one of the best investments in my
quarantine and 25% when a love seconds
like three four hundred dollars like
that's a chunk of change off yeah that's
a good promo code yeah it's not
sponsored like I do only we're not
making anywhere from much I'm really
just trying to make your quarantine a
little easier so actually a lot of stuff
happened in like the last 24 hour maybe
the last like two three days that we
didn't talk about yet that I actually am
really excited to talk about I have a
lot of thoughts on the Michael Buble
story okay and I have a lot of thoughts
on this Amy Schumer story okay I love it
I look forward to getting into it I feel
like I have a lot of housekeeping news
just from my personal is sake we're
recording a new episode of the redheads
this afternoon I'm so excited this book
has been like a fan favorite it's it
kind of was not a book I had ever heard
over a lot of the redheads had heard of
but everyone has been absolutely loving
it I'm so excited to chat with the girls
about the book we always do this thing
on the redheads where we cast like the
movie version of the book which is
actually a great concept yeah and so
half of this book is like 15 years in
the past and then 15 years forward so
we're gonna have to cast like young Matt
young grace old matt old grace and
Jennifer Garner and I've really been
inspired by little fires everywhere cuz
they did such a good job not only do we
have to find actors who like fit the
descriptions but they have to look like
each other so I really look forward to
seeing what everyone comes up with make
sure you're subscribed to the redheads
book club literally if you start the
book right
you could finish it before the episode
drops tomorrow because you can't put it
down it's a page-turner it's called
before we were strangers by Rene Carlino
and then on tomorrow's episode snitch
will choose the next book for the next
two weeks because then the next episode
will come out the thirst first Thursday
in May there's also a new episode of the
snatchler if you watch that new bachelor
show that looks like trash but I heard
was actually pretty good she read her
Nicole recap it and they both also read
Colton's book so if you wanted to know
what's in the book but you just don't
care enough to read it they're gonna
recap the book and just basically tell
you the important parts and today's
episode of the snatchler is called
listen to your snatch and so proud to be
Tibet is harder to that's something that
there's a podcast episode in the store
called listen to your snatch because
honestly we should all be listening to
our snatches there's also a new episode
of Margaret Joseph's podcast so if
you're looking for stuff to listen to
there's so much here at toast news
network thank you for being here so much
new episode of mood with warden
Elizabeth there's gonna be a new episode
of maternity live tomorrow I actually
like never watch our show it's just like
I lived it why don't have to watch it
but I rewatched yesterday's show because
I want to show been like a couple funny
things that I watched the whole thing
yeah and honestly like it's such a good
show
I agree watched something that we said
yesterday and I was crying laughing yeah
and you don't know when you're doing it
like am i doing a good job is this a
funny show only until afterwards do you
really realize like I feel like I did
really good or I didn't really perform
well and yesterday I felt like we had a
hilarious show I agree also there's a
siren I'm like so excited because it
means it's nice there's life happening
in New York City like but we are gonna
mute our bikes we're gonna move for the
siren
wow I never thought I'd miss a siren
yeah honestly the sirens give me like a
really bad sense of anxiety I guess
because it's like an emergencies
happening but not for the person who
like needs the ambulance more for my
show which is terrible terrible but what
you were saying about our show being so
funny in sometimes we don't realize it
until after a very true and also
sometimes what happens is I'll say
something really funny and you're
already on your next thought so you
don't process it and vice versa
sometimes like total like that account
toast quote of the day they'll put in
something that you said that was so
funny and I'm like wow I didn't even
register that cuz I was like thinking
about my next thing yeah so when you
watch it back there's a lot that might
have been this yeah that's very true
very very astute of you to observe um
also something that I want to discuss
with you I don't know if you're ready to
talk about it no I know you're gonna say
no you're gonna insult my son like I can
just tell my hello vibe oh my god not it
cold looked out at the oh and you were
saying how he looked like a sewer rat so
I just wasn't enough for you to disgrace
him when all he does is love you it's
not his fault that he hasn't like been
groomed yeah he said he he was like okay
when he got here he like farted and he
just like was looking kind of gross and
Jackie called him a sewer rat and like I
didn't say anything but I just thought
you were like gonna dive deeper into
that sentiment and I was gonna have to
defend myself I would never I understand
these are tough times like I'm not using
heat on my hair like look I mean that
his hair is a little overgrown okay what
I was gonna say and the reason I looked
at because you got stuck in the--it's
great last night oh my god you know
that's happened to me one time before
it's so painful but like okay so Theo
obviously was crate trained and we still
have a crate in our house just because
he loves the crate he doesn't need it
anymore
it's his home it's his bedroom if we
what we haven't left him alone in the
apartment in like six months but if we
ever do he usually ends up in there it's
like a really good when we first started
training him the trainer explained why
it's like so good for their behavior and
it's just like overall calm I don't know
whatever there's a bunch of reasons for
it I don't need to explain myself and
now we just keep it in our bedroom and
he he likes to sleep in there a lot but
like we don't let him sleep in there we
like to make him sleep like in our laps
and last night he like went in and we
pulled him out and we made him lay with
us and then me and Ben we're just like
talking and we look around we're Co he
like had snuck back into his crate I'm
like no no no but then I was trying to
think like I keep dragging him into my
house like why don't I go into his house
and it was a little hard for me to get
in there but like it wasn't anything
crazy like I do have a fat back so like
hey I knew that it wouldn't be like easy
to get out but I didn't I didn't see
myself being stuck like because every
time I tried to pull myself out of the
crate I hurt so bad those it's metal
ball yes I mean so hearing people and I
have very sensitive skin like if you
pinch me in certain parts of my body
like I will feel the pinch for 30
minutes like sure and also you're a
major hypochondriac no not a
hypochondriac I have a very low
tolerance for pain like I I can't take
hot baths
I have very very low tolerance for pain
so maybe a normal person could have just
[ __ ] knock themselves out but I really
really got stuck and honestly I mean
been like shove my phone into the crate
because it was too funny so funny and
Ben was telling me from outside but that
mean - like seriously pausing like get
me out it hurts so bad actually but look
this morning if I bruise it oh actually
it hurts to the touch it really hurt and
I was like ready for bed I just what it
was like a two second thing that was
like not supposed to get me stuck it was
really traumatizing and Thea was like
get the [ __ ] out of my face good fine he
was like stuck so close to each other
this is the Oh like concern at all or he
was like that's what you get it was just
annoying because like that's when I wish
he was a human being like where he could
have been helpful like no he literally
just sat there and looked away yeah can
you why is this woman in my bed Jeremy
totally that's what you get like leave
the kids alone leave the kids alone
well I feel as though that's all she
wrote it is definitely she I told her
she said that's all I wrote oh okay
great well without further ado without
further ado we actually have so much to
do today because we're doing here
toasters ban from bros recap HSM 3 recap
so it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of the morning toast
and that's your Jackie but you know I
feel like we're all feeling down and I
wouldn't want to give anyone another
reason to feel down like maybe give them
a case of RDH that would be bad so let
me just come right out and let everyone
know that today's episode is brought to
you by a new sponsor come to kill her
which is perfect because I didn't know
about Hunter Killer and I've been
searching for like things to deal with
specially at night like having a date
night and me and men have been playing
so many games and Hunter Killer is
fabulous if you want to take advantage
and spend time inside at home with your
husband your kids who ever hunted killer
is reinventing the way we interact with
murder mysteries you can go from being a
viewer safe in the comfort of your own
home to an investigator actually
involved in solving the case the latest
season starts with a woman Julia who
unearths the corpse of a famous actress
from the 30s in her family's theater
the Board of Directors trying to push
Julia out which is so funny okay and the
theaters reputation on the line you will
actually help solve the cold case
investigation before it's too late
with each delivery you'll sift through
piles of documents evidence audio
recordings and even files eliminating
suspects until you crack the case
it brings the fun animus of an escape
room to your house it's easy to play so
whether you're solo or with family and
friends during this time you can even
join their spoiler-free online community
that has over 100,000 members so you can
share theories and help each other out
along the way hunter-killer has over two
thousand five star reviews on Trustpilot
it's no wonder why people love them so
much
the idea of like having a game that
keeps getting update it's almost like a
podcast like you get new episodes you
get new deliveries it's actually really
genius and especially during quarantine
it's so fun to like throw yourself into
something like that takes you a long
time and it really helps if you're like
fighting with your husband it could be
real community building
yeah totally right now for our listeners
you can go to hunter-killer dot-com
slash tous and use the promo code toast
at checkout for 20% off your first box
head to hunt a killer dot-com slash
toast for 20% off to show your support
for our podcast and use the code toast
hunter-killer comm slash toast me and
Ben have started it it's so fun like it
takes over our whole dining room and
it's just it's it's just [ __ ] too
like it's so sad but like in this
quarantine times like to be a part of
something yeah totally I mean even me we
got our boxes a few weeks ago and I'm
now like a huge game person who knew
like we were even playing games on the
zoom and Jackie's fun and interactive
and creative and I respect it Jackie's
getting into games and that's truly like
all I can hope that's when you know that
the quarantine has taken over
totally also today's Wednesday so we're
going to be doing deer toasters which is
our advice segment we'll do it at the
end of the episode afterward we recap TV
and stuff and if you ever want to write
into our advice segment it's totally
anonymous and it's steer toasters at
gmail.com shoot us a note anything from
weddings to bosses to whatever
well we'll hook it up great first story
Amy Schumer changes her son's name after
realizing it sounded like genital the I
feel pretty star revealed her decision
to change her 11 month old son's name on
the newest episode of her podcast three
girls one Keith on Tuesday
Schumer and her husband Chris Fisher
named their first child gene a tell
Fisher born May 5th with his middle name
serving as a tribute to their good
friend comic Dave Attell she said do you
guys know that gene are babies
is officially changed its now Jean David
Fisher it was Gina tell Fisher but we
realized that we by accident named our
son genital genital Fisher which is like
a hemorrhoid genital Fisher yeah which
is like a piece of dude it's like
something in your ass can I just say
look I've been so connected to this
story because when she announced that
her kid's name was Gina tell Fisher like
she's a comedian I thought it was a joke
like I thought she named her kid genital
fisher like but that she wasn't that
wasn't the kids actual name like it was
just a joke she played on the public
yeah and so I was waiting for like the
real one and then I found out it wasn't
a joke but I'm so glad like she
addressed it no totally and she said
that she's killing two birds with one
stone by selecting the name David for
genes middle name because it's her
father's middle name and it's a tells
legal fur scene there's a reason for
everything yeah there's a reason for
everything could you imagine like the
schoolyard bullying is Jean a boy or a
girl
gene is a boy oh okay yeah gene GE and
you know I know but then I thought it
was a girl so I'm like a girl middle
name David it's like kind of weird but
actually about that weird no it's why so
it's not weird it's the gene like that
that guy yeah the guy from Willy Wonka
yeah gene Davis David gene I know what
you hold on this is on the TV Marlo G
gene Willy Wonka gene Wilder that yeah
yeah yeah yeah that didn't feel like
what I was looking for it didn't feel
like what I was looking for you there
but it sounds totally right but it's
like according to Google that's Willy
Wonka
no but that that is who we really that's
what I was talking about yeah me too
hold on now I need to look at famous
genes I feel like there's our one
totally boses him
gene Wilder yeah that was him Gene Kelly
Gene Hackman oh my god we love him he's
sweet you know Heartbreakers ease I feel
like Bobby loved his wife oh my god I
love he's my favorite gene I just love
it that Amy Schumer has a podcast and
you know when she first came out the
podcast a lot of people were really hard
on her she it's like a lot of criticism
like every time she does something it's
because she was like so she likes shot
to fame like even though she was working
as a comedian for so long she just like
it looked like a Liz Oh like an
overnight success and people were just
like so excited for her to fail and I
love that she's like in season favorite
podcast she makes like a million dollars
a season and like she doesn't doesn't
have to work and I just love that for
her yeah
I love that for her as well because I
feel like she really appreciates the
fruits of not having to work completely
and especially now that she has a kid
and she like doesn't want to be away
from her son I've been actually really I
in followed her and Instagram a little
while ago she just became like so
preachy so boxin even though I was like
agreeing was like a woman's right to her
body like I just couldn't deal with like
some of it was just like too much but I
recently followed her back because her
baby content is so cute and I love
seeing her house it's so nice I think
she looks on the Upper West Side oh she
lives in the city
yeah I'm pretty sure yes she's really so
New York she's so I love her so much
she's funny and I just can't wait for
whatever she's doing next I think she's
like a new series coming out but it's
been a minute since we got like scripted
content from her that wasn't at her
special what's her series love Beth I
think I saw somewhere there's also
something she's working on something um
that's like based on something do you
know what I'm talking about her no no I
don't even and then we've got making it
up I thought I heard maybe that was Pete
Davidson he's working on a TV show like
about Pete Davidson a guy from Staten
Island right yeah okay yes sorry similar
family yeah um
anyways I'm glad that she righted this
wrong I know this is really funny really
funny in like this would only happen to
her and I just ice we have no respect no
choice but to respect someone who can
laugh at themselves a hundred percent
and like own it Lisa and also I she must
have done this a while ago because she
was just like casually telling her
friends on her podcast so she didn't
make it a big thing like oh you guys
were right I'm change like as everyone
was obviously calling it Jenna told
Fisher before but like she just did it
quietly um can I just share like a
personal life update that's like kind of
a big deal yeah I forgot to mention
during that part of the show I've had it
during the life update part of the show
yeah I had got a popcorn kernels stuck
in my back bottom left wisdom tooth for
three days now and I have all my wisdom
teeth grown in I have a big mouth and
there was space for them and they grew
in straight and like they're totally
fine and normal knock on wood but I
thought that like maybe that like that
blessing was being cursed and I wasn't
sure if there was popcorn kernels stuck
in my tooth or that like my wisdom teeth
we're now starting to give me problems
and I was like screw rubbing them so
hard with the toothbrush and I don't
have any teeth picks in my house so this
morning I picked up some of those like
dental you know they look like dinosaurs
like yeah it's like a tooth pick and
floss
yeah I picked it up at 7-eleven
7:11 and I stood in the mirror and I
watched the colonel come out of my shoes
and it was literally like having an
orgasm it was like the best feeling in
the world like I I want to do it again
well yeah it was so exciting what a
thrill it is the throw I'm someone who
gets food stuck in my teeth all the time
I'm always at the dentist like figuring
stuff out I got my wisdom teeth out
because of it cuz if you leave that food
stuck there too long in sexual rot it's
not good not good
how many of your wisdom teeth did you
get out I think I got all of them out
cuz it was like I was doing one do them
all was it painful no I mean they just
like knock you out and then you know you
have the recovery but I think actually I
had a really clean break from them you
know they weren't meant for me yeah
mm-hmm that's always good
Ben's were impacted so they had to break
it and then like take it out piece by
piece because you can't pull out a tooth
that's not like straight and he said it
like the sounding of the crunch was like
he like he was obviously like on drugs
but he hurt yeah I'm breaking the bone
like he said it was hard well it's not
but I got my wisdom teeth out when we
were doing the breath so a lot of you
guys were on that journey with me you
know and it was like really a short
journey I think everyone was just I was
like I just don't remember it I took off
like one Friday and I was back to work
on Monday and like my face she worked so
hard I think I just had a good I had a
really good dentist actually he was like
super toasty and he like wanted to come
on the show after and like talk about
teeth it was Ben's dentist too right no
Ben's dentist I go to Ben's dentist but
then that dentist recommended the
surgeon to do surgery yeah I'll go he
was pretty fabulous I love a fabulous
dentists Immokalee this next story is a
story a couple that I never thought
would come together but that I am
personally shipping very much okay it's
a reality Steve exclusive reality sees a
person reporting this he tweeted that
one of the more random bachelor couples
that I can't say I ever would have
guessed I don't know how long this has
been going on or how serious it is
but I can confirm that Victoria fuller
is currently together in Iowa for the
week with crystals
discuss I love crystals like even though
you know he is a big controversy like
arguably bigger than ours which is crazy
because in my mind ours is the biggest I
can't believe like what happened to him
like in the sequence of his life just
like was not what I expected
and I really do want happiness for him I
just like don't know if this is it
I don't know I'm like weirdly here for
it by the end of the season I actually
really like Victoria Muller also I feel
like you learned a lot about about sure
contestant once the show is over and I
haven't heard a peep from her so she's
not very thirsty that's true um and I
guess maybe she's really looking for
love like anyone who would just like go
to Iowa and shack up with crystals I'm
so here for it and even though what
happened what crystals like went through
was not good like what he did was very
bad when we knew him on the show like he
was a charming guy you know so I
actually I feel like and they both now
been arrested I feel like they might
have a lot in common you know they say
actually I agree like it's it really is
true that like opposites do attract and
in a lot of relationships like it takes
a more tempered person to like bring a
psycho you know what I mean like not a
psycho but like there's just two
different types of personality being and
again in the yang yeah and I do really
see like if this were to be like the
truest love story of our time like I do
see how like a very common tempered
crystals like could be the guy to like
take down like the wild child Victoria
but not even he doesn't need to take her
down but just to balance or like settle
her down yeah yeah no it's it's not I
mean when I heard it was ran I mean like
now that I think about it it's not the
craziest thing I've ever heard I just
want to know like did she fly to Iowa
cuz it's a very frowned upon yeah how
did she get tire I agree and she's only
there for a week so she's just like
traveling around the country she should
stay longer yeah also speaking of people
traveling during quarantine there's a
little Twitter drama going on Lala and
all have now traveled I think again
they're in like a new quarantine spot
it's like this beautiful beach house I
don't know where it is but they're under
fire by a lot of tweeter people why are
people upset because I cannot supposed
to travel but they're using a private
plane I'm just like I'm guessing they're
using a private plane I don't know that
you can do that I'm just saying that's
what people are saying like I mean you
know I'm like I would go for a llama any
day but like if you have access to a
private plane like use it yeah I guess
the thinking is like if you're in New
York or LA you could potentially be
bringing traveling with the disease yeah
and then like starting another hub and
wherever they were quarantined but they
were supposed to be getting married this
weekend which is so sad so maybe they're
just trying to do something nice
probably yeah but also I mean I
to pick up someone's battle like yeah
and by the way nobody that's such okay
to call like even yesterday oh my god
you're so right like even yesterday when
we were talking about Aaron foster like
what she said sorry wasn't a big deal
and like people were like I can't
believe Claudia and Jackie went to bed
Aaron posture it's like why am i falling
on like on the sword for like someone
else's comment like I make my own dumb
comments like that's my cross like I can
live with those but like why am I always
out here like defending or like coming
for people like it's I know it's our job
but like what you just said I so
wholeheartedly feel like I feel like
people are always getting messages I
can't believe what you said about like
this certain thing I'm like it'll be my
job to talk about it like why am I
getting in trouble for talking about
someone else's thing that got them in
trouble yeah I still feel that I'm just
not going there like yeah Twitter do
your thing do your thing leave us out of
it okay this next story cloudy and I'm
talking about all morning cuz it's
really crazy oh my god it's horrible
we sauna Lopilato defends Michael Buble
amid malicious backlash she said quote I
have no doubt who my husband is so
there's a video going viral
it's Michael Buble and his wife Louie
sauna and it appears as though you
should watch it for yourself to make
your own judgments because we were not
like gonna tell you what to say tell you
what to think but it looks as though he
elbows her and then realizes what he did
and like brings her in for like a big ya
know it was just like a what he did
wasn't bad but it was a very small
window into a type of behavior that is
toxic as hell like he they obviously
they started this live stream and they
had both planned on planned on saying
hola chicas but she just said hola so
when she just said hola he like elbowed
her and gave her face that like really
is not normal and in his brain it was
almost like he's so well-trained in
hiding that type of behavior that he
instantly looks like ready to play it
off as a joke you have to watch it we'll
post it on our Instagram it's just a
very worrisome video nothing happened
she doesn't get me slapped in the video
like it was just don't worry something
the face said he pulled after it cuz
like an elbow can be different degrees
of like force you know so it wasn't so
much elbow but his lip face after in the
dynamic and then just like the
aggressive pulling up her in anyways
people have obviously had their thoughts
on the video and
she has put out a statement defending
her husband she said we get together
every day with my husband to stream live
and bring a bit of joy entertainment in
hope and we have to deal with hearing
and seeing from ill intention people who
come out saying things about her family
without knowing anything about us and
she's you know saying that people are
it's not there was no negative thing
happening there I mean this is just like
a really hard story because I feel like
if what she's saying is true and there's
nothing bad there then it's sad that
everyone is you know assuming these
terrible things about that sad the other
the other ways situations are very sad
one is much much more severe like that's
like the possibility that she's in a
relationship and it is now quarantined
with someone who is potentially abusive
and now the world knows about it
but he wrote that statement yeah so it's
awful and here's just a reminder that if
you are quarantined with someone who is
physically verbally financially or
otherwise abusive please reach out there
are hotlines you can do a me on
Instagram just know that it's not normal
in any way and you should seek resources
yeah it gives me the biggest gives me
the biggest especially because we're
quarantined yeah look obviously an
abusive relationship is horrible on a
normal day but in a quarantine day I can
only imagine that it's worse or like an
abusive parent like anything an abusive
home life is just horrible horrible so I
mean the video is watch the video and
decide for yourself but she's saying
that you know there's nothing nefarious
going on and that you know people are
taking it and making it something that
it's not that's possible
because across people myself included we
love to do that yeah but I don't know I
just saw something in the video that
really did not rub me the right way are
you right okay Bethenny Frankel actually
helped Leah McSweeney get on Real
Housewives of New York I mean that's not
shocking because they're 2 fabulous
women so I just started following Leah
on Instagram because I think she's
fabulous and I'm all about her and I saw
Joseph's tagged her so that's how I
found her Instagram yeah
seemed and then I saw that she posted a
video was like a cute little Bravo clip
asking how she got on the show and she
said actually I got on through Bethany
but that was it I was like oh
interesting but now she's being
interviewed on Darren Carbon Liz Liz
cully's podcast called
scissoring isn't a thing which is a
hilarious name for a podcast hosted by
lesbians and she explained how she was
quote psyched when Bethenny Frankel
randomly began following her on
Instagram she said then actually I got a
text message from our I have a facialist
that I've been going to for a very long
time who unbeknownst to me is also
Bethany's face facialist who's the
facialist I would love to know I don't
know but she does great work so she's
like you know Bethenny Frankel wants me
to ask you if he would ever be a
housewife of New York McSweeney said it
was the weirdest text message she's ever
gotten but that's how her name was given
to the hit Bravo series she also said
she still has never met the Skinnygirl
mogul and probably won't anytime soon
because she has since unfollowed her on
the social media platforms quote I don't
think it's a personal thing I don't know
what it is you know whatever but I mean
I only have gratitude towards her that
is so interesting also so I started
following Leah and her clothing line
married to the mom is still in business
it's still in business I just assumed
that it wasn't but it is and it's so
cute and I'm all about it
I love Leah I'm so confused about this
whole story it was Bethany casting like
a replacement was Bethany at first
planning on staying on the show and like
she was helping producer to bring
someone else on or was she like just
throwing someone in so she could bounce
maybe like a combination of all three
but you know her and Andy are super
close and maybe she just wanted to help
them find someone who would give that
sort of balance and rational thinking to
the to the cast and like if she is like
really replacing herself because it does
feel like leah is you know Bethany 2.0
yeah she should have some Satan who that
person of course and it's kind of how
Jill Zarin thought that they brought
Heather and to replace her because
Heather was like Jewish and like loud
spoken and Andy said that was in fact
not true they couldn't be more different
it couldn't be more different but I
could see how Jill Zarin would think
that I do because she's like such a
narcissist and thought like the whole
show was about her and they needed a
replacement but the whole show really
was about Bethenny and they do need some
like very outspoken cool girl
replacement and I think that leah is I
mean it's only been one episode but leah
is doing a great job she I love her I
know she would have to do something like
so crazy for me to turn on her at this
point because she hasn't even done
anything other than be herself and I
just like who she is like I can just
listen to her talk I like her interviews
I like her bucket hat I'm just into it
she hasn't done anything other than be
herself and be friends with Tinsley and
like honestly her staunch defense of
Tinsley like couldn't make me hate her
because I hate Tinsley
but it doesn't and that just proves how
great she is you know what else is
interesting though so bad
to me recommended her but then she met
Tinsley and came in as Tinsley's friends
so is like our Bethany and Tinsley still
friends enough that like Bethany would
say hey meet this girl yeah there's a
lot of like press right now and I don't
know if it's just like people being
bored and making up stories or actual
beef between like production housewives
and Bethany but I hope that's not the
case because I would really like in my
wildest dreams like hoped that she would
someday come back we talked about this
story on Monday how Bethany said
something and apparently to Caston the
producers are so pressed about it I
think it was a page six exclusive so I
think it was really like Ramona and
LuAnn going to page six and like saying
because they're upset by what she said
cuz she talked about how the ratings are
not good and they're making it like more
than it was I'm sure the girls are upset
but I don't think and he gives to [ __ ]
not not even one um also talking about
like the sadness that is Real Housewives
of New York is making me so excited
because tonight is the premiere of Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills it is yeah
we get Garcelle and then Sutton they
keep referring to Sutton as a housewife
so maybe she just comes in later
sometimes that happens it's like I don't
think they would bring on like most
sometimes they do bring on two new
housewives um in the first episode but
like sometimes we start to meet someone
in them by like Episode four she has a
diamond that happened with Katharine
Edwards and who was on at the same time
as her um
Eden Sassoon yeah I think they brought
one of them in later on but then also
they do weird things in Beverly Hills
like a remember miss Marissa Hermer
who was being tested one season they
were gonna make her a housewife the next
season but they just wanted to like
introduce her she was so boring that
first season she never made it as a
housewife yeah on my time hop I actually
just got a notification like five years
ago um I was chopping up Bergdorf's and
I ran into Marissa's or Renee asked her
for a photo that's so crazy
yeah so random that's so weird how you
even I barely remember her she wanted
like dad was father-in-law
I said wretch was like a big big guy in
in Hollywood like in the movie industry
and her last name's Ermer
means something means something it's
like if your last name was like
paramount I don't know we're like wine
Stevie okay and final story a little
content news because that's all we've
been craving NBC Universal is officially
entering the streaming wars with peacock
peacock launched today
Wow so peacock will become available for
Comcast Xfinity x1 and flex customers
across the country beginning tomorrow
which is today April 15th NBC Universal
executives expected to be available to
all eligible customers by the end of
April it doesn't cost anything on extra
on top of your regular bill this is an
early preview of the ad-supported
subscription service this Comcast still
plans to roll a peacock tune on Comcast
subscribers on July 15th originally
Comcast and NBCUniversal we're going to
use the 2020 Summer Olympics as a tie-in
for a bigger peacock launch but that is
no longer the case looking for getting
it out yes so right now they have like
15,000 hours of content I think and they
are doing like this whoa we're all out
doing it first to their existing
subscribers and then more and more and
more and I mean this is the time for
more streaming services to pop up so
there's no time like the present and I
love that it's free like especially
because it's by NBC like [ __ ] I pay
cable like I have spectra I'm like I do
all that to make me now pay more would
be annoying and the fact that they're
like honoring and my cable bill for a
streaming service I really appreciate
that's like HBO also like I really
appreciate they don't have to pay for
another I pay for HBO cable like that
should get me into HBO whatever yeah go
now or whatever it's called this is this
is exciting I'm excited to see what
content they do have I feel like we've
been talking about it for so long but
like it's hard for me to parse out what
I'll see HBO
this is gonna have the office ah is it
it's my understanding that it was going
to because I'm seeing some of the shows
included our Law & Order SVU
30 rock Friday Night Lights Jurassic
meaty and Ray well I'm not seeing
anything about the office I mean that
it's not did I tell you that I started
off like so get no they took it off no
Zach watches it oh definitely time yeah
I thought it was like a friends that got
taken off for a streaming service but
maybe I'm wrong I think it's still on
Netflix did I tell you that I started it
no cuz you knew better I had watched
like the first three seasons in high
school like in an attempt to like be
funny cuz like boys we're watching and I
just thought like I wanted to have
something in common with boys and it was
like whatever and I restarted it and you
know what I can't watch it like the
camera I get that it's supposed to be
filmed like a documentary or something
but it is such a shaky camera like I
literally could vomit watching it like
might go through the blinds and then
like the
twisting I actually want to vomit it
makes me nauseous I'm so sorry buddy
else have that problem
I'm so sorry maybe you should stop watch
and speaking of streaming services I
know I I come in here a lot and I talked
it about Hulu because like literally
it's one of the worst streaming services
just in terms of navigation like I will
like be watching One Tree Hill go and
get a snack and somehow I'm three
episodes behind like it never can
remember my place and just like
navigation is terrible but I spent
almost all day on whoo yesterday and it
really is really like up there for
content yes but it is really annoying
that like if you want to pause and come
back you're in Siberia yeah good luck
finding where you were but honestly it's
like the only platform I can open down
like fine stuff to watch because it has
all the Jersey Shore which I'm which I'm
watching and that's all of One Tree Hill
and it has song land song land oh my god
you guys to go back to first episode
yeah it was so good on it okay come here
come again to our TV recaps okay without
further ado now it's the TV recaps first
about song land Lady Antebellum on the
premiere episode of song land which is
the best most talented show on the
television I'm obsessed with all the
judges I don't know who I love more but
I think it's Esther Dean she's just so
I'm a Ryan Tedder girl like I think Ryan
Tedder is so talented and I'm and I love
his work and I love shame I love his
work but there's just something about
Esther's personality where it's just I
just want to be her friend you know yeah
and she's so talented yeah anyways Lady
Antebellum on song land was everything
of the sort now in the end I understood
why they chose the song that they chose
because it's the song that they came
there for a summer Bob before the
amphitheaters amphitheaters yeah but I
wish that they had also taken the song
the long way home oh I totally disagree
I thought that Ryan Tedder song was the
best one and you know what it was a
little unfair because all of the songs
that I get that songs change all the
songs sounded pretty similar to the
songs that they came there sounding like
but chain mcanally there wasn't one word
that was the same from that girl song
I'll drink to that like every word was
different it was more reggae like it was
just he basically wrote a new song and
now this girl gets to sing it right in
credit because that's how the show works
but like he it wasn't really fair like
he wrote a new song yeah but I mean
that's the writing process you take it's
still the same idea which was her idea
for the song of like champagne night but
that was there I didn't like or just
drinking that's a country song that's
not an idea no I would agree also her
original song sounded just like rich by
Mara not the same thing
and in Aladdin it sounded a little bit
like it yeah no Zack and I were sitting
on the couch like we're like we know
this song yeah I had the same thought
process I just I love the concept like
the premise of the show it's like so
pure and you would think that like I
would find the parts in the beginning
boring where like other people are like
who I don't know or singing songs that I
don't know but like I get like
teary-eyed every time these people come
out and sing songs like it's just so
nice when that guy was saying that he
performs at the montage and yes in Park
City yeah and they were like oh my god I
know you I was freaking out yeah that's
I guess I get so crazy
that's just like weird coincidence I
also just love Lady Antebellum and I
feel like I never really get to hear
them talk like they just sing I know and
like Lady Antebellum uh but it's it's so
they're so interesting to me because
they're one of my favorite bands of all
time but like the music speaks for them
I feel like I'd really don't know them
on a personal level like I do with some
other art you don't know the dynamics of
the band really but no sometimes I get
the dynamic like that I wish I didn't
know them um just like from them being
on stage but they're just together
they're magic yeah and I thought this
song the long way home like it wasn't
the song they came there for they needed
a summer Bop but I would have loved to
hear them just have it for their next
album or whatever um cuz I thought it
was so beautiful
ya know I it it always it gets to the
point where there's never really like a
clear winner like I'm always like
shocked at what they choose but I think
that Lady Antebellum gave a great reason
they're like I'm not not choosing this
song because I don't like it it's just
not what we need in our catalogue right
now which is such a good answer I'm like
you can't feel bad losing to that yeah
they do need that like I mean now there
is no empathy right or but you know
everyone needs that boppy summer anthem
that's like you know it's summer nights
y'all yeah that's not the best Rascal
Flatts song but it's the one we play
when we want to get turned up exactly it
was just a really good episode I love
Lady Antebellum and all the episodes are
good but it's really nice to watch an
episode where you know that the artists
are also songwriters oh they're such
songwriters that third guy who is the
Kevin Jonas of Lady Antebellum yeah it's
like trippin with talent yeah so crazy
when he was just like talking about the
stuff it was so impressive so like even
last season like some of them my
favorite episodes were random only
because I know that these people are
actual songwriters and they're not just
like saying like I love the Jonas
Brothers but like either up
a little boy he's like Nick was just
like trying really hard to prove it like
he is a songwriter when like Kevin and
Joe we're like we're not we're just like
here to have fun so I really like when
like the songwriting is the focus of the
episode and that's like Lady Antebellum
they said we all started as songwriters
and then we ended up like becoming a
band but I love when like songwriting as
the art is like made it's the for way of
the whole thing yeah so it's never I
mean I knew I was gonna love the lady a1
because they're like top five of my
favorite artists but sometimes it's like
I love the Meghan Trainor episode and
she wasn't she's not even like one of my
favorites I'm so excited for next week
Luis FONSI
Oh was he next yeah and so I'm really
excited just I've never I don't know him
that well I'm excited to get it to know
his personality and see what songs they
choose because like Esposito is you know
everything they have gonna get the next
Estus hito on song they have amazing
people this season Florida Georgia line
Ben Platt they have good people last
season too but like I just I'm loving
the respect like it's an honor to be
chosen to be on song line because you
don't have to be just like famous like
you have to be talented ya know if
you're not watching song land you guys
are truly missing out on one of the
greatest shows ever
I agree it's um it's really like Shark
Tank is what I feel like it is yeah it's
like Shark Tank for the music world also
it's one of the shows that Zak and I
watch together
yeah they say we have to stop because
it's like you know how we fight over
shark day because I'm just trying to
talk like Oh which song would you choose
this song sounds like this and he just
like can so I think I should start
watching it alone um also just like a
weird thing that happened in the episode
when they turned um losing you into a
duet and they brought out that girl from
the Goldbergs oh I don't know her yes
okay she is like such an interesting
character she was on x-factor for
singing their daughter on the Goldbergs
yeah are you sure positive she does look
like her but I remember her name being
Hayley Geddes hold on interesting let me
double check that I'm right because I've
been following this like Haley yeah
because it's NBC like Haley Orange or on
Tia yeah so she was on x-factor I think
she was like putting a group and then
like she never made it far and then she
got cast as an actress on Goldbergs and
like hasn't been like thriving now as an
actress but she keeps popping up in
other places like doing random singing
things so I think she's really a singer
at heart she was excellent yes she was
it was a nice it was a nice touch I
honestly Lady Antebellum could have like
done all those songs and
so they kept on saying like oh it's
gonna be like heartbreak or downtown but
to me those are kind of the worst lady a
songs they're like the cheesy sing
downtown is the worst song and I'm sorry
cuz Shane mcanally wrote it and they
were like yeah but we made amazing
downtown and I like damn that just
should not speak for your work because
downtown is one of my least favorite
Lady Antebellum so yeah this song or
like even like bartender the songs that
they release the singles are the worst
ones the songs on the album's the slower
ones are the best one merican honey I
feel like at a certain point they need
to realize like we just want to cry like
we don't want it like but they're
obviously leaning into like the data and
the data is telling them that people
like Brian is doing well yeah yeah so
they're like hell yeah alright when she
was seeing that something like that's a
song already yes that's a song called
hell yeah alright
that girl who wrote who ended up writing
the winning song with Shane McAnally was
so cute she reminded me of like Shawn
Johnson she looked like and also
Giannina Aubrey O'Day like could be a
star like she was like she was in
Nashville she's like cute she's talented
okay she's not going to me but I'm just
saying like she could have been like she
could have been like a like it was like
a million you know oh it's not a story
but rustling Cayley dickerson are
pregnant I merely a lot of stories this
morning actually had to get rid of some
and never happens most people are
surprised but I'm happen to be related
to a psychic named Olivia who actually
told me like three months ago that she
thought Caylee was pregnant just like
the vibe she was getting maybe it's her
pregnant girl intuition but I'm really
happy for them yeah they see each other
um so we're gonna jump into Deer
toasters which is our advice segment but
before we do that it's time for a word
from our sponsors today's sponsor is
thrive market thrive market do you just
love thrive market it's an online
membership based market on a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
for everyone they've guaranteed savings
where you can enjoy member-only prices
up to 25 to 50% off traditional retail
prices they have the highest quality
healthy and sustainable products you can
buy thousands of wholesome food home and
beauty products curated just for your
members their members everything you
need from organic and non-gmo food clean
beauty safe supplements and non-toxic
home plus ethical meets sustainable food
clean wine and more and you know in this
day and age it is so hard to get a
grocery order but it's even harder to
get a healthy grocery order and our
market is just churning out orders it's
that you need whether it's like home
cleaning supplies food it's like a
full-service market plus they do a lot
of good for the planet orders over $49
are shipped free and delivered with
carbon neutral shipping from their zero
waste warehouse and then they have a
Giving Program called thrive Gibbs
it's a one-for-one membership matching
program so every paid membership sponsor
is a free one for a low-income family so
you can feel good about getting your
sweet snacks and then also helping a
family in need so it's fabulous
the thrive gives program is everything
that you need you can choose your
membership so we both have the 12-month
membership because it comes down to $5 a
month but if you're not sure if that
market is the right fit for you you can
easily give it a try for a shorter
period of time
I'm thrive membership is risk free you
can take the first 30 days to determine
if thrive market is right for you and if
it's not just cancelled within 30 days
um thrive market akhaten everything you
need so check it out and thanks for
sponsoring today's episode before we get
into your toasters we have to recap the
under pump rules because their t-shirts
to me is too distracting I can't think
of anything after it yes so it always
has to be last okay Tommy canty second
week Vegas wedding the whole episode was
truly boring as hell for me I genuinely
thought that at first that the brob was
like a real thing and I was like oh my
god and the fact that it ended up being
planted by Lisa is like low-key a really
evil prank tably not even evil so
inappropriate she's their boss and I'm
sorry like you can try and fool me Lisa
like I know you don't wear bras like
that like I'm 25 and I don't wear bras
like that like only porn stars wear bras
like that and I know that you don't like
that was like an attempt for you to make
me think you're something that you're
not know is just an attempt at like
making it was like the most scripted
sort of reality television and
Vanderpump rules has always prided
itself on being not that because it
really just generates itself and the
whole episode was so scripted it was
like a long ad for Vanderpump rules
cocktail garden and I mean I am the
sweet I'm glad for them that this air
during quarantine because like watching
them in Vegas I didn't care where they
were going I was just jealous jealous
jealous and loving every minute of it
like I want to get on the zip line in
Vegas I've never wanted to do that in my
life so it also made me realize like if
I found out today that something
happened with our paperwork and me and
Ben actually haven't been legally
married for the last three years like I
would be excited I would do the same
thing like I would go to Vegas like
that's out that actually the premise of
the the trip was actually really really
fun and sweet a hundred percent like but
and it was a great crew but yet nothing
happened why didn't they go anywhere
they just went to Vanderpump rules for
dinner it was a great crew but like why
was max there I have no idea they needed
to tie into the old crew when they
needed someone to sleep with that
Vanderpump constant invited Dana yeah
because she's actually friends totally
won it made no sense where they should
have invited everyone like that would
have been so fun I was really like team
Kristin when she was crying to scheana
like I felt really sad for her and I
also like I pretty much have agreed with
Stassi up until this point like Kristen
needs to make sure you choices and and
start to grow and and until she does
that I just don't want to be around her
that much but like leaving her out of
your wedding when she was a bridesmaid
is so drastic and so hurtful and I just
don't think it was so necessary because
at the end of the day what she did is
annoying sure but it's not like that
that evil it's just so random
yeah like the meanness I don't know what
it can't be the fact that Kristen is
making poor choices when it comes to
Carter like that is this is a dramatic
reaction if it's just that yeah and also
it's like okay I understand Kristen's
making poor choices so we're gonna cut
her off but the fact that like she so
desperately just wants their friendship
began like should make them be like okay
if you like give her a chance yeah
exactly you know what I mean like maybe
they would cut her up people do grow
apart but like you don't grow apart from
someone who desperately wants to be your
friends you know but you're right the
whole episode was really just an
infomercial for like Lisa's partnership
with Caesar's Palace like the general
manager wanting to come on the sweet
thing like heard with the keys like it
was just so staged and like I'm really
getting I never thought I would say this
I'm so over the show and even watching
like I can tell like Jackson Britney
like more so Jax like he's so over like
he's checked out of everything like he
goes to Vegas any parties but like he's
just not into it it's not because it's
not about him like even at his wedding
he was just like not into the filming
accident a part of it like they're over
it I'm over it like it's just at this
point I'm liking the younger people more
which is crazy like it's crazy I don't
mean they went to Vegas great crew and
absolutely nothing happened right
the idea for a Vanderpump suite at
Caesar's Palace is an amazing idea there
is it like it's gonna be so cute it's
gonna be like Villarosa
yeah and everyone bachelorette parties
are gonna stay there it's genius it's
really genius I'm happy for Lisa and her
business but as far as like the whole
episode and it looks like next week we
don't even get Bo proposing
they're strong users now that's gonna be
four week lead up for a proposal so the
whole season's about a proposal no it's
traumatic no it's it's pulling teeth
yeah also I did think it was kind of
weird how Lisa very graciously like flew
Tom and Katie out but she was on the
Caesars plane like why didn't she just
bring the rest of the group it was only
like seven more people I don't know and
then Lalla and Randall were already
there like obviously private the day
before right I just I don't know it's so
weird it was really not a good episode
like it was really testing me oh except
when they had the fake Sheena from
Vanderpump garden that was so funny him
and sauce he was like I thought she was
gonna get on the bar and sing sweet as a
silver I was like laughing at first I
was like wait that's not the song I'm
like oh that's my boy Jackie literally
me too as I do leg Sheena yeah but that
whole scene with like her waking up in
Max's bed was the most fake thing ever
my way back to me facetiming his boss
know when he has a girl in his hotel
room
it was so planned that they're gonna
call about invoices and Max is gonna say
something about trashing the room so
Lisa wants to see it she's gonna see
that hand in the bed like it was awful
awful like it was a hotel it was a sham
it was insulting to our intelligent
group and I'm I'm so annoyed that I
changed my TV input for that
also Tom Sanibel referred to himself
when he got up extra as the king of
extra and that call you made about him
like trying to brand himself so he could
write a book or have a podcast or a tour
it's so true it's so true love that yeah
okay tear toasters all right bye segment
you can email us each a 7-3 recap your
oh god I'm sorry to your toasters today
I don't know why I'm sorry talk about to
your toaster let's talk about HS I'm
sorry okay HSN three guys um the
culmination I it's funny I've seen the
others used so many times and I've seen
HSM three a lot because I knew every
single song except for the few random
weird songs that just did not hit like
when they gave Gabriella her solo like
gotta go my own way song but it wasn't
got to go my own way they tried a little
gospel thing and just it did not stuff
up it felt that the movie itself is so
good because we finally get the
production value of a theater movie
because the first two were made for TV d
comms and they were good but it's not
it's not movie theater budget no and
some of the scenes some of the numbers
were show-stopping like that I wanted
all Sharpay and Ryan like oh my god it
was like they just had money
losing out from everywhere they had a
little too much money because they gave
us the boys are back in that junkyard
which absolutely nobody needed like the
boys bad bear they back from even Chad
and Troy are fighting that chad is like
literally the least understanding least
compassionate friend ever like he's so
one dimension losing both ketball like
you can't be in drama do basketball and
Troy it's just like saying like you know
there's more to me than that and Chad's
like how could there be more it's just
like I can't believe they've been
friends since kindergarten right anyways
eventually like in all the movies Chad
gets on board of course um what was
Martha Joe Oh Martha has become head
cheerleader and they did this so subtly
and I actually love it because in the
first movie she's a brainiac and they're
telling her to stick to the status quo
even though she likes to pop and lock a
jam and break and then by the third
movie they don't even mention it but she
is head cheerleader for the East High
Wildcats vs. West High Knights game it's
beautiful and then when they're doing
the senior year musical and the main
cast members are there practicing then
Martha comes in and she's like I brought
some backup dancers and she obviously
brings a quad and then it really gives
them the senior year musical like the
gravity that it needs that's that's
actually beautiful it was really
beautiful and subtle you know and Disney
I don't think they're really known for
that another by um I loved watching the
characters develop like first of all
Shar Peis like wig and extensions like
from the first movie to last movie I
think she's literally wearing a wig in
the first movie by the last movie she
has like you know that real 2008 long
hair Chloe
like Miley Cyrus used to have and it
just it brought me back and it was good
hair you know they got that good quality
hair that's big and even Vanessa Hudgens
her style in the first movie you need to
see the shoes that she was wearing can
you please Google Vanessa Hudgens High
School Musical one outfit I hope you can
see her shoes because they were a church
to say what it seemed oh she wears the
same shoes the whole movie they're like
jazz shoes with the kitten heel no oh I
see they're crazy but then by the third
movie like her flower child Coachella
personality has started to come through
you know influence some of the styling
decisions that's fabulous
and she really is such a cutie and now
Zac M&S I was reading a relationship of
their timeline they were dating or
meeting a relationship of their time
their relationship they were dating the
whole time the the movies were being
filmed and like by movie three like
they're so in love with each other like
I swear they should have had
two of them say I love you in the movie
because I think it was just a really
good example of a relationship for young
kids yeah and they think that they were
truly in love because at the end like
when Troy is on stage and he was like
I've chosen basketball and it was a and
everything and he's like and I've chosen
the person that makes my heart so happy
or some [ __ ] like that and he goes to
Berkeley to be closer to her and it's
like he's got the best of both worlds
you know yeah I mean either they're
really really good actors which I don't
think is the case or you're truly
atleast losing out of them and like we
said that's what makes the difference
between a very very good romance movie
and a stellar bomb because these two
people can't keep their hands off each
other right even their kisses are just
like good kisses as opposed to CG
that's why I think like the whole Fifty
Shades thing was like a huge failure I
completely completely agree if those two
people had been obsessed with each other
like we would it would just take the
movie tour and go ahead like any sexual
chemistry mm-hmm and that's why I think
even Hunger Games like who it's like who
did she even end up with yeah she in
love with I don't even know they were
both so random so random ends up with
Peeta but it would never happen they
couldn't have had less chemistry and
also her and get her and Liam Hemsworth
I wish like I feel like they definitely
kiss they definitely hooked up on set
yes no there was more chemistry between
them yeah which is why you like rooted
for them and he's hotter and taller than
Peeta yeah so anyways overall just the
whole thing and I think back in the day
we used to think that HSM 2 was like the
dog yeah the failure but I loved HSM too
I think maybe at the time I didn't
appreciate it because like maybe you're
still living in the suburbs and I had
beautiful vistas to look at but now I'm
like this Country Club situation like
it's so stellar the songs were so good
it's it's so good and I loved how they
really change made it different from HSM
one been by HSN three miss darbus is
back and she's really like the moral
compass of the whole dance you need to
re-watch it just for her because like I
think he would have a deeper I think
justice for miss darbus I think I am mr.
what should have been served
me all along Sharpay is still like so
self-centered and nothing redeeming
about her in the third movie but at
least she like keeps it contained to
just herself the people were like I
think justice first Sharpay comes from
the third movie I was like oh she must
like maybe she was one who like flew
Gabriella back from Stanford or
something right no she's still all about
number one
she throws Ryan under the bus so many
times and there's never any redemption
now I think I might watch our pace have
this adventure to see her character arc
okay but um I love that at the end
ultimately Kelsey and Ryan get
scholarships to Juilliard and I can't
think of two more deserving people yeah
Kelsey was like the quiet hero but she
wrote all the songs and they're fabulous
songs and she deserves to go to
Juilliard agreed um in the first movie
when during auditions she's wearing this
v-neck t-shirt from Urban Outfitters
that would have like this crazy pattern
on it and I had it when like the movie
came out and like I never in my life
felt so cool wow I'm like calcium like
you see that cherry yeah I but it's from
Urban Outfitters sickening sickening
honestly that was a fun trip down memory
lane it was so much fun so I don't know
if you're participating in totes movie
today I'm gonna tell you guys what I'm
watching tonight to continue this trip
tonight I will be watching the Hannah
Montana movie and beautiful and then
after that when I get around to it I
will be watching the last season of
Hannah Montana Hannah Montana forever
I'm actually the middle of it on Disney
Plus Disney Plus is such a fabulous it's
so fabulous so if you want to watch
along with me I'm so excited to watch
Hannah Montana the movie it it has
literally been one of the like forming
for sure like foundations of who I am as
a person and I look forward to to seeing
her it's also the first movie we went to
at midnight like in theaters that came
out on a Friday and we went at Thursday
on 86th Street there was literally not a
seat open it was so crazy it was so
crazy and I thought I left my iron on
the whole time and I was like I had a
pit and it was unenjoyable but then I
saw it two more times in theaters so
that I could like you know undo that
feeling but I still remember it um I
don't want to rush you but like is it
time for dear testers now eighties time
okay dear toasters I need some advice my
boyfriend and I had been together for
about two and a half years we lived
together and our quarantine was going
surprisingly well until last night we
got in a blow-up fight drunk of course
and now we haven't really spoken I'm
sure you two can imagine how hard it is
dancing around each other in a one
bedroom in New York City apartment what
would you do to reconcile in your mind
how you how you'd recover if you didn't
get back together I'm worried I said
something in anger that one will never
recover from
have you ever said something brutal in a
fight and come back to it I hate being a
downer during this period but you feel
like my friends and always keep it real
but make me laugh and I just want to
know how you'd cope help us scared and
sad Jean PS is merch shop is everything
of the sort and retail therapies but I
needed xoxo thank you for the laughs
I'll be thank you for writing in but I
need to know what you said yeah and
here's the thing I've said things that
were like super harsh and not like
hanging over us and that even like to
this day it's like that thing that I
said but it always comes from some sort
of truth you know when it clearly no I
wish I hadn't said it because it hurt
your feelings like that is how I felt of
course no no I
I only say things for the most part that
I mean so even though it like I've said
some really mean things men and he said
some mean things to me actually not
really I'm usually the one who says the
mean thing but sometimes I've said it
and it's just what not what he wanted to
hear but what I needed to get off my
chest and I really don't have regrets
about that yeah are two people in this
relationship and I understand that your
feelings are hurt too but like I
obviously was driven to a place to say
something
yeah and Cokely with normal Jonah is
probably a nicer way to say but the
sentiments that you're feeling it's like
that is actually how you were feeling so
unless you said something that
completely you don't mean then that it's
actually easier because you can say I
didn't mean that I just you know saw red
and I wanted to say the meanest thing
possible yeah I know what you said yeah
that's really tough to have that sort of
fight during quarantine imagine like
breaking up during quarantine and then
you're quarantined oh my god that's
awful I need more information sister and
let me know I'm sorry I can't get advice
to things that are so general I
understand you not wanting to tell us
just think of like the worst possible
thing and she said it well like what is
it I cheated on you or I think you're
ugly think you're like it wouldn't be I
cheat on you that's like she did
something bad yeah and if she didn't do
it she could say I mean right right yeah
okay um just work through it like even
if you want to break up with him like
just wait till all this is over it's
just like you need time so if you guys
need to stay in separate rooms for a day
two days like let it blow over this too
shall pass if you're meant to you guys
they're like you guys will get through
it sometimes fights make your
relationship a lot stronger bs you've
said the thing you the other person
knows how you feel and now you they can
work on making it better and changing
that thing that upsets you so much so
fights aren't always a bad thing
in fact more often than not it's a good
thing like when you're not fighting in a
relationship it's not a relationship
that's true it's like a friendship and
in the words of Garrett had lung and
Granath Paltrow in the iconic movie
Country Strong which maybe I will watch
tonight timing is everything
yeah when you ain't you had said timing
is everything and I tried to interject
with that quote but like you wouldn't
let me as you had like something else
smarter to say so I just like wanted to
get in my quote with you no doesn't make
sense you were saying like take time
apart because I'm done it's time is
everything yes beautiful
okay next up Thank You Claudia that's
beautiful dear toasters I have become
really close with my neighbor who lives
across the street
she's about 65 years old and a widow of
two years she recently discovered
Instagram and has been talking all sorts
of people stalking all sorts of people
she now thinks she has been talking to
Carlos Santana romantically she came to
my house a couple weeks ago with a pizza
saying Carlos ordered her three pizzas
to her house I don't didn't think much
of it until I realized he probably had
to ask for her address to order pizzas
to her house oh man I texted her but she
didn't reply the next day I went to her
house to have a talk with her about the
whole thing she let me in and I saw that
she was playing Santana YouTube videos
on her computer she was smiling and
singing along it was so sweet and she
was so happy that I couldn't tell her
she doesn't have a lot of family around
so this is so this Carlos person whoever
it is probably means the world to her
however I am concerned about her safety
because she lives alone with her dog who
has everything who was her everything
just passed away and the advice on what
I should do sincerely a concerned friend
no matter your concerns are legitimate
like if someone from the internet is
asking for your address it's not just to
send you pizzas it's to come kill you oh
my god that is so upsetting well they're
so pure her dancing around her kitchen
listening to Carlos sent up like maybe
it's Carlos Santana
I'm sure this my first like at first I
want to be hopeful so I want to say like
I feel like between all of the toasters
in the universe like someone has a
direct line to Carlos Santana and can
find out if he's talking to like maybe
Carlos Santana's married and like and
we're out
oh I'm like blowing up so funny I'm sure
it'll put to god it's that situation oh
my god that is so funny I actually can't
breathe oh my god got to tell this woman
like honestly but what can she do the
guy has her address now just keep an eye
out I don't know this is a good episode
of catfish be a damn ax
yeah but it's like the catfish I guess
they have their addresses and you know
things could get crazy really get her a
home alarm system or something you're
like I don't know a guard dog a
Rottweiler or something let's also check
in with Carlos Santana you know what we
can find out if he's married yeah also
this is gonna be crazy
who is Carlos Santo you know his
musicians all in the game know he's
featured on that song that's what I
thought um Carlos Santana relationship
let's see hmm
I think he is married me that doesn't
relationship isn't a good keyword and
what is to marry or wife yeah yeah
that's good or husband actually yeah
Carla he proposed to his drummer in 2015
that's so cute was married no no okay so
he married oh yeah I know he's married
to Cindy Cindy Blackman Cindy Lauper No
okay well honestly you need to protect
this woman like this is really not funny
and like this is why certain people
shake hands I would love like not to
break up in her marriage but like if
this was Carlos Santana yeah okay final
one mmm oh this is good - my favorite -
my sister's an MLB pitcher recently to
UM to be on Instagram we talked for a
few weeks and then he started texting me
it's not super flirty and he's kind of
weird I'm an accountant who was busy I
don't respond super quickly and he's
busy with his business outside of
baseball so we maybe send a few texts
every few days I'm interested in him but
don't know what to do
keep his attention or be more flirty
also I don't want to be too all over him
please help a toaster out you're the
best
this is such a tough time to be texting
with an MLB player because like you
can't go on a date obviously we used to
know a girl who like had a business like
DMing players yep oh and actors too and
then like like sexting with them and
like ending up like getting to meet them
and like going on dates yeah it wasn't a
business like no it was a hobby it was a
hobby where she would just like hook up
with famous athletes and famous people
um no I think it's a tough time to be
like texting with an MLB player that you
can't go on a date with because like you
said you need to keep his attention I
think he probably gets like any nude
photos he wants at any time and like you
probably want to date him I'm assuming
less pressure that's just a lot of like
whether you want to send nude photos or
not like it's a lot of pressure to know
that like that's something that other
girls are sending to him um I have no
idea like I've never been in situation
either and like you have so much time to
fill with conversation like you don't
want to burn out less is definitely more
I just do your absolute best to be like
so funny so smart so charming while also
being very like subtle and like
hard-to-get I don't know I'm going so
bad also that sounds like a lot of work
and I feel like actually what my work
here is like going silent you know and
then he'll be like oh what happened to
her and then like that's a good way to
keep someone's interest to be like a
little mysterious but if you're an MLB
player like I'm sure like you have a
bunch of girls like some of them you
know I'm sure they all respond I'm sure
there are some that it's possible these
are there none that don't until like you
could differentiate yourself by doing
nothing this is very exciting for you I
decided to hit his DMS it was she said
he recently dammed me on Instagram so he
likes what he sees
interesting well that's up to you you
just gotta like bide your time like play
like run out the clock okay warranty
exactly the shot clock is running down
and just cycle dribble dribble
guys like your Nathan Scott just dribble
you gotta gotta gotta get your head in
the game that's that's you know what I
love about High School Musical what all
of them like they always referencing
back like it's so meta they like in
every movie after the first one they're
like we're all in this together
and then they'll be like what team
Wildcats what team Wildcats did you have
in the game it's like they're
referencing themselves and even the last
song in the movie it's high school
musical there singing a song about the
title of their trilogy it's cool it's
really meta and self-aware and I'm all
about it that's funny
mm-hmm I like that um I think that's it
that's our show for you guys please
follow me on tic toc like I really want
to get to a hundred thousand and I'm at
70 so girl with no job follow Jackie two
if you want Jackie oh let me at Jackie
oh problems premium content yeah thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
iHeartRadio cast box all the places so
ever you listen to podcast find out some
morning toasting leave a five star view
about a beautiful stunning and smart we
are we love you guys so much we will see
you tomorrow in studio bye bye